yeah no I mean I mean I'm it's
interesting to talk about the crazy
thing is yeah Tony I wish I had a ton of
like memories and stuff I was just so
young and I was just so you're partying
too probably I was partying I'm just
like college nineteen honestly how much
did you get
I mean I feel like I probably you know
didn't please a lot of women you know I
mean they had they had they had [ __ ]
back then imagine being 19 you're good
looking dude right I'm like an 8 as long
as I brush my teeth I'm an 8 yeah yeah
yeah good look at 19 I look dude I
realize that I look like to do that
always
people always accuse a farting I feel to
party and he was a funny probably you
know then Ryan actually funny right and
that's how he got the [ __ ] Road rules
at college what do you how many people
audition for that 10,000 people
no like 50,000 every year yeah it's
crazy right yeah so yeah so that he beat
all those people out and whatnot you
know man and then they all move to Los
Angeles and became casting director
executives and then got angry at me
whenever I walked into there we do now
though Thea was now we go over to UM
Gilbert and we do a question from the
internet and we Gilbert honestly is uh
is um it was a popular name on a little
house on the prairie do you remember
that he watched that as well it is if I
didn't know there was a name do they get
that where where is he from again yeah
yeah he's from Atlanta you guys get one
yeah
good show yeah it is and that would be
my fifth actually Michael land oh yeah
yeah it's not why is that a good show he
said Michael and so yeah I've seen it
Rod's about it I want to talk about a
little house and a pair real quick okay
I think that he's crossed the line with
me really yeah what you cable I am
drawing the line at [ __ ] little house
in the Prairie get up big [ __ ] what
worked all summer to go see you when I
was a kid and you weren't there dude the
cleaners Chet
[Laughter]
vo a reveal that I speak you bro yeah I
opened up store for two months and I
nucleolus covers I closed it down dude
we could go on tour right now and you
could be the first Asian that a ton of
people have ever met how great would
that I know be real way she's come here
she'll be real right now no but I'm just
saying what town are you from Luke from
Covington Lousiana Huffington yeah let
me tell you something right now Lee
Harvey Oswald went to our middle school
Wow Wow
thank you incoming incoming ten right
call being dong selling swords bro Bobby
look like even selling swords you know
in covington yeah it's better than
incoming ttan yes there are no asians in
Cummington yeah i don't think there are
any more I mean they might have had one
you know at a certain point or a couple
of that came through in some sort of a
program but I don't think that if you
ask somebody like where can I meet some
Asian people here nobody's gonna know
Vietnamese there huh vietnamese
vietnamese damn you know let me ask you
then I ate I love the vs Man I'm
spending all the time running around the
Vietnamese I love the Vietnamese I've
been to Vietnam I've been to a Saigon
Shang pen yeah I mean I mean I mean I'm
a big shot and I get you murdered so he
asked her questions from the internet
what's a call it's called unhelpful
advice he's gonna do it in the new week
we answer okay great but I will tell you
that I could take you to places towns
right now we would show up and it would
be like come meet the first Asian you've
ever met and you would be that first
though we got it we have to you have to
go we have to do what you like to do
then we have to film it oh dude I could
take you to at least willow am I gonna
die
no they're gonna love it how it's gonna
come in and see the Asian girl in a
freak show like a like I'm the hairy
face boy
yeah what no we had a hairy face boy in
our time this kid named Thundercat yeah
he go yah yah the disease the hairy face
didn't know he had long hairy face
disease yeah very
he says cornrow his cheeks love the
black girls with cornrow his cheeks in
the summer a little bit of relief from
the heat but um but yeah I could take
you to towns right now and I could meet
seven and eight nine year olds that have
never met an Asian oh I see okay well
let's do that one day I think we should
do that I've long I mean it would be
really fascinating don't you thorny I
think it'd be funny I think I'm very
funny so you'll put a tent up where they
couldn't touch me or now it should be a
staircase up to like a like a tent or
something yeah yeah let's do that let's
do that yeah cool let's do that yeah
yeah my first Asian you know yeah with
Bobby on hopeful advice with Bobby
kalila Anthea VAR presents my first
Asian coming to Louisiana Wow bro bro
that's pure talent that is uh hello
[Music]
[Music]